as we continue our special coverage for
mental health awareness month we're
looking at the mental health strains
that many first-generation immigrants
face in the u.s lilia luciano spoke with
thea pham an asian-american immigrant
who went viral on tick-tock after
sharing her emotional story she talked
about the expectations she says she
faced particularly from members of her
own family
i love my parents
but there is no boundaries
because i am just a wallet now it was a
moment of vulnerability i am the
retirement fund for 27 year old theopham
that resonated with millions on tick
tock i feel trapped and betrayed by my
own culture and my own family
pham is a first generation immigrant
from vietnam she came to the united
states when she was 15 after getting a
full scholarship to a boarding school
what was the plan when you started
applying to these scholarships my
parents struggled a lot financially my
whole job in the family was to focus on
education because that is the way we
lift ourselves out of poverty so that's
a lot of the expectation is put on
myself pham went on to get her phd in
neuroscience from ucla she's now a
biotech venture capitalist
i remember my mom told me like you have
to get a full ride to a college like if
not like don't even bother going home
because like if you return home that's a
failure so you don't have a place to
fall back on at home yeah i feel bad
because i know they love me deeply but
it's also
i felt like a conversation about mental
health and mental wellness is never ever
discussed femme says after posting her
tick tock video she quickly realized
there were other first generation
immigrants who felt the same way do you
remember what your intention was when
you made the video it was just like
literally a video diary of two myself i
had like 20 followers then i was nobody
and i post this video at my most
vulnerable moment
and then all of a sudden i woke up to
like millions of people and i was
freaking out what did it feel like in
that morning after i felt so much shame
because
i love my parents so much and i felt
like i was bringing dishonored by
sharing my struggle and i read all the
comments and i realized like oh my gosh
like i was not alone
hundreds of thousands of people
commented on her video with their own
struggles which left fam wanting to
learn more about their experiences
i'd love to meet you she created
multiple zoom town hall meetings where
first generation immigrants like her
could share their stories together
may champion was a participant i felt it
deep like i felt her tears champion
immigrated from hong kong when she was
five i think we all just feel better at
them the day hearing that you know we're
not the only ones we're not alone
vanessa peso is a licensed trauma
therapist
it is a very brave step to be so
vulnerable and to be so open because in
a lot of different families i think
across the board that's not necessarily
something that's encouraged but one
thing that it does is it almost gives
other people permission
to start to speak up about their own
experiences
pham says she's still working things
through with her parents
but her validation in life no longer
comes from fulfilling
expectations what is success do you know
success is no longer surviving
it's not
it's thriving like i want to thrive
being myself
and have a fulfilling life
i think taking care of yourself and
leading a life that you envision you to
live
would be so much more fulfilling for cbs
mornings lilia luciano in los angeles
we did reach out to fam's parents they
declined to answer any of our questions
so many people suffer in silence it's
just it they feel trapped between these
two cultures and being new americans it
must be really
really troublesome for them i i can new
generation confronting an age-old
problem that a lot of immigrants have
confronted before yeah now she's giving
voice to so many